the harsh truth of the film industry is
that movies are business investments in
the best case scenario a movie thrills
audiences and makes producers happier
and wealthier but sometimes a movie can
be so bad so bizarre and so damaging to
the reputation of a studio that the
people in charge will willingly kill it
keeping it away from audiences and
writing it off as a lost cause here are
a few movies that if the studio had
their way the public would never ever
get to see here with entertainment so
refreshing so hard lifting so
satisfactual you will want to see it
again and again rad released in 1986 rad
follows a young unsigned BMXer striving
to come out on top in the world's
greatest off-road bike race it's gnarly
with a capital G and it's camp value is
off the charts do you try to understand
the only thing I'm good at is riding
this bike reviewers hated it blaming
stilted performances in a totally
inexplicable plot viewers with a healthy
sense of irony however can still find
plenty to appreciate like a scene in
which characters take their bikes to the
school dance and on to the dance floor
rad may fail at what it's trying to do
but it goes above and beyond as a relic
of its era so it's well worth tracking
down online or on unofficial DVDs it was
popular as a rental in the days of VHS
but the studio has all but abandoned it
since unfortunate considering its
growing value as an examination of 80s
culture at its most totally radical
[Music]
Martin one of the late George Romero's
best and most interesting horror movies
is also his hardest to track down you
can find a copy of Night of the Living
Dead anywhere but if you want to
legitimately see Martin you'll have to
pony up for an out-of-print DVD or track
down a bootleg copy the story of a young
man in Pittsburgh who may or may not be
an ageless vampire Martin is a movie
that sticks with you
it's hero who appears unsure as to
whether or not he's a monster
is sweet and sympathetic which makes the
scenes of him drugging cutting and
drinking the blood from people all the
more disquieting don't be afraid you'll
just go to skate I don't have to hurt
you it's not the quality of the film
that keeps it out of viewers hands
because it's actually pretty highly
regarded among its fans
it's reportedly not available because
the producer who owns the rights for its
release simply wants too much money for
it it's a shame it's out of print
because it's a unique wonderfully
crafted take on the vampire fable and an
example of how to remix old monster
stories in a hauntingly effective way
the last movie there's a lot of
interesting things going on in Dennis
hoppers second feature 1971's the last
movie the problem is they're not
presented in an interesting way you
really can't fault Universal Pictures
for burying this movie and never
releasing it on DVD Roger Ebert wasn't
kidding when he summed it up as a
wasteland of cinematic wreckage it's
even edited out of order to the point of
incoherence the title card for the movie
doesn't appear until 26 minutes in I
wanted the government and different and
better than it's ever been done a few
viewings could help you cobble together
the meaning of the movie which follows
hoppers character as he goes native in
Peru and contends with locals who can't
tell that movies aren't reality but it's
a joyless aggravating experience despite
the criticism and the fact that the
film's performance kept hopper out of
the director's chair for nearly a decade
afterward Hopper supported the movie up
to his final days screening it on his
own while trying to secure a home video
revival let it be the film that captured
the Beatles struggling to recapture
their chemistry Let It Be has developed
a reputation over the years as a
portrait of a band dissolving in reality
it's not as explosive as has been
implied unless you were naive enough to
think the band mates never bickered
while it may have been a bummer at the
time the movie is an interesting loosely
constructed chronicle of the recording
sessions leading up to their legendary
final rooftop
formants it doesn't make anybody look
good but it doesn't make anyone look
that bad either and any Beatles fan is
apt to find something intriguing in the
film's many moments whether it's the
implied drama of Yoko Ono lurking at the
fringes of the studio or the way the
band lights up when it comes time to
play some music it's an intriguing
document with the rooftop performance
Serena's an unlikely swan song to one of
the most successful musical runs of all
time so why hasn't it ever been released
on DVD or blu-ray while it's
consistently been suppressed through
threat of lawsuit by its image-conscious
cast the reality today is that for a
layman audience the movies just not very
good as a movie it's got a name with
structure and lousy sound it's a fans
only experience of a depressing time
that a lot of casual music lovers
probably wouldn't care to see the Star
Wars trilogy in what is perhaps the
biggest strangest case of cinematic
injustice on this list the original
three Star Wars movies undoubtedly some
of the most influential films of all
time are extremely difficult to find in
their original form for decades now each
release of the movie has shown
incremental changes in their content all
in the name of moving quote closer to
what's been called George Lucas's
original vision the most egregious
examples of the cinematic revisionism
where the Star Wars special editions
released in 1997 in an overt attempt to
replace rather than complement the
trilogy as those special editions were
developed it became increasingly harder
for actual original versions of the
movies to be found the shortage of
official releases has led to fan edits
of the special editions which keep the
cleaned-up visuals and sound while
ditching the extraneous junk the fact
that fans have had to do this with some
of the highest-grossing most culturally
embedded movies ever is nothing short of
absurd and the de Disney releases the
originals in a restored format will be
cause for celebration speaking of Star
Wars celebrations the Star Wars Holiday
Special
with a legendary reputation in the world
of bad entertainment the Star Wars
Holiday Special is so far afield from
what makes the franchise great that it
boggles the mind
released after the success of the first
movie this largely plotless over long
ugly and aggressively unentertaining
slog poses itself as a variety show in
space which leads to surreal moments
like Bea Arthur singing to aliens in a
Cantina and wookiees watching what can
only be described as holographic dance
porno
I am your experience
I experienced me experience I am your
pleasure this is how I mean it's
frequently been reported that George
Lucas has said if he had the time he
would destroy every copy in existence
and really someone should have let him
ironically or not there's no fun to be
had here the Star Wars Holiday Special
again is that it commits the cardinal
sin of the crappy movie it's not just
bad it's boring to Chewbacca the Ewoks
films less notorious than the despised
holiday special the Ewok films are
interesting Star Wars Apocrypha they
happen on a pretty faithful version of
Endor an actor Warwick Davis returns as
wicked who made his first appearance in
Return of the Jedi the problem
well the Ewoks are more articulate than
they were in Jedi and hanging around
with a stranded human family we came on
a StarCruiser and we crashed
even less tolerable is the decided lien
on Star Wars plot turns both movies take
the first film caravan of courage
includes a magical pond the traps people
bootleg looking fairies made of light
and the unbearable moral message that
love is the strongest force in the
universe
what is this interstellar shut up anyway
caravan of courage is sequel the battle
for Endor immediately goes full oddball
with the introduction of an evil
shape-shifting sorceress whose outfit
looks like something the costuming
Department on Xena Warrior Princess
would have rejected is too tacky there's
also a horrifying alpha like alien
creature that lead actor Wilford
Brimley's character lives within the
woods easy to make fun of there
entertaining experiences if you watch
with the proper mindset but they're not
actually good or interesting eh even the
prequels can't live up to that standard
the Carter this documentary is a fairly
straightforward look at the life of the
rapper Lil Wayne recorded around the
release of the Carter 3 in 2008 what
makes the Carter such an interesting
document is how revealing it is it's
remarkably unflattering to its subject
and the damage is all self-inflicted
even as it demonstrates how talented the
rapper is at what he does Wayne
selfishness self-destructive habits and
personal rudeness make him a very
difficult figure to life a look into the
mind and life of an artist you would
probably never want to meet it's a great
watch and though it's been sporadically
released on iTunes
currently not officially available with
legal challenges from wayne's camp
blocking the release of the film
song of the South though the notion that
Disney song of the south takes place
during the times of American slavery is
a misconception the reality isn't much
better
this is radioactive material and
Disney's portrayal of the post-civil war
south as a chipper place where former
slaves sit around singing songs all
night feels like it's glossing over the
big picture the story of song of the
south is actually about a young white
boy in his relationship with Uncle Remus
a former slave in the film the white
people are without a doubt the bad guys
and Uncle Remus is the hero but none of
that matters because the setting is so
jarring that it's not shocking at all
that Disney doesn't want it to readjust
some thing people can buy as of the
making of this video Song of the South
has never been released officially on
home video in the United States in all
likelihood
unless Disney experiences a drastic
change in its artistic mission it
probably never will be
glitterati Roger Avery's adaptation of
Bret Easton Ellis's the rules of
attraction is an underappreciated dark
comedy bearing a loose and loopy
structure filmed with daring stylistic
touches one of the more memorable
sequences occurs in the middle of the
film when a world travelling character
named Victor recounts his extensive
European travels in a breathless kinetic
montage though the sequence barely lasts
four minutes Avery reportedly shot days
worth of footage for it with Victor's
actor staying in character as he takes
drugs seduces women and otherwise
behaves like the Alpha and Omega of the
boorish American tourist archetype Avery
assembled this footage into its own
movie called glitterati which is one of
the more legendary hard to see films
from recent years which author Ellis
described as like a documentary with a
fictional character in the middle of it
Lionsgate films distributed the rules of
attraction but not glitterati and the
reasons come down to what is likely a
combination of quality and legality
according to Ellis for many legal
reasons it will never see the light of
day you can't really show glitterati in
public it's not possible there are a lot
of people who would be very upset
Avery himself has called the process of
making glitterati insane and ethically
questionable to this date he has only
showed the film at screenings that he
hosts and the chances of that changing
anytime soon are vanishingly small
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]